thank you so much for inviting me for
this talk and thank you so much for
being so numerous today I have a lot of
things to talk about but what's
interesting in my mind is that these
things are linked together in a really
interesting way at least that's what
I'll try to convince you about so the
title talks about system to cognition
which is about high-level cognition and
that's connected to consciousness as
I'll explain it's also connected to
issues that are very important today in
machine learning about generalization
out of distribution and it's also
connected to the notion of agency and
reinforcement learning and how agents
face problems that standard static
machine learning hasn't been looked
looking at enough already
so deep learning has made amazing
progress in in the last few years and
decades and some people think that it
might be enough to take what we have and
just grow the size of the data sets the
model sizes computer speeds just get a
bigger brain but I I'm not quite of this
opinion I think that we're missing out
in qualitative ways in order to approach
human-level AI we have currently
machines that learn in a narrow very
narrow way they need much more data to
learn a new task than our human examples
of intelligence they need humans to
provide high-level concepts through
labels and they still make really stupid
mistakes they're not very robust to
changes in distribution there are
adverse real examples and things like
this and so some people contrary to the
first ones that I mentioned think that
we have to start a threat start afresh
and invent something completely new to
face these challenges and maybe go back
to classical AI to deal with things like
high-level cognition what I'm trying to
tell you about today is that I think
there is a path to go from where we are
now
extending the abilities of deep learning
to approach these kinds of high level
cognition questions of system two so I
talked about these two things system 1
system - let me try to be a bit more
precise I really got introduced to these
concepts by reading the amazing book of
Daniel Kahneman which I suggest you to
look at Thinking Fast and Slow and
introduced two kinds of cognitive tasks
system 1 are the kinds of things that we
do intuitively unconsciously that we
can't explain verbally and that we can
in a case of behavior that are habitual
this is what current deep learning is
good at so if you're driving a car and
going back home to a place you know you
don't need to pay a lot of attention to
the road you can talk to the person near
you on the other hand if you're in a new
city and you don't know the way maybe
somebody told you directions but you
have to really pay attention to every
corner and you have to read signs you
have to be on the lookout and if
somebody tries talking to you you will
ask them to you know please let me drive
so what's going on there is that you're
generalizing in a more powerful way and
you're doing it in a conscious way that
potentially you could explain so if I
asked you to add 34 and and 56 you can
do it in your head but it's going to be
sequential and slow compared to a
calculator the kinds of things that we
do with system to include programming so
we come up with algorithms recipes we
can plan you can reason we can you know
used logic usually these things are very
slow if you compare to what for some of
these problems computers could do and
these are the things that I'm gonna
argue that we want future deep learning
to do as well so here are some things
that I think we're missing in order to
approach human-level AI with deep
learning we need to work better on out
of distribution generalization and
transfer so when you learn a new task
you want to be able to do it with very
little data
we want to be able to handle these
high-level cognitive tasks that I
mentioned including using these tasks to
force the learner to discover the kind
of high-level representations which deep
learning was supposed to be about in the
first place you know deep learning was
about learning multiple levels of
representation with the highest level
supposedly corresponding to the kind of
concepts we manipulate with language and
many of these concepts have to do with
causality the kinds of concepts we
manipulate with words tend to be cause
or effect and once you start talking
about causality you have to also talk
about the agent perspective something
that the mainstream of machine learning
hasn't paid enough attention to not just
because we want to solve reinforcement
learning problems but because we want to
we won't have machines that understand
the world that build good world models
that understand cause and effect and
that can act in the world in order to
acquire knowledge so a big theme of my
presentation today is that these
different questions are not independent
research directions they are connected
when you make progress in one you can
make progress on the other and
understanding how they're linked can
help us plan a path for our research so
let me talk a little bit about
consciousness and the kind of
functionalities that I think we need to
add to machine learning so this is the
road map for this talk I'm gonna start
by talking about the need for having
machine learning systems that can handle
changes in distribution and why it's
particularly important for agents
because of non-stationarity zin in their
environment then i'm gonna talk about
the building blocks that I think can
help us get there in the last few years
maybe unnoticed we have added things to
the deep learning toolbox in particular
attentional mechanisms which I think are
actually the key to move to the next
stage that I'm talking about and in in
this part of the talk I'll also tell you
a little bit about how much work has
been done by our colleagues in cognitive
neuroscience
to better understand human the human
side of the equation then I'll talk
about several priors that may be linked
to consciousness so the main theme here
is that there's an advantage for human
beings to have these high-level
cognitive abilities and and so these
advantages you can think of them as
assumptions about the world so usually
we talk about prior so you can think of
them as organisation so the first one
that I'll talk about is the idea that
the Joint Distribution between the
high-level concepts can be represented
by a sparse factor graph any joint
attribution can be represented by a
factor graph but the sparse one has a
different story and then I'll talk about
another prior that has to do with how
the world changes and this is going to
connect with the notion of agency so the
fact that most of the time when things
change in the world it's because agents
like people do something so we intervene
we do things and the hypothesis that I'm
proposing with other people is to
consider those changes as localized in
some abstract space and if if we use
these hypotheses I'm going to show
through some of the recent work we've
done you can actually discover
relationships that are just causal
relationships between variables yeah we
also talked about meta learning which is
connected to the problem of learning out
of distribution and the final bit of my
presentation is going to be more about
the detailed architectural structures
that we should explore to introduce the
kind of compositionality that system to
processing requires and in particular I
think we should be moving towards neural
nets that can not just operate on
vectors but also operate on sets of
elements sets of vectors sets of objects
that are appointed all that that can be
referred and operated on by dynamically
recombined modules so that's it that's
that's the end of my talk this is the
right now I'm gonna go a little bit more
detail on each of these points let's
start with changes in distribution so
the classical framework for machine
learning is based on the hypothesis of
iid independently and identically
distributed data that means the test
data has the same distribution as the
training data and it's very important
because if we didn't have that
assumption then we would not be able to
say anything about generalization why
would a function learned on some day
they work on some other data right now
unfortunately this assumption is too
strong and in reality is not like this
most of the data we get isn't iid and so
in practice what many people do in
industry or in academia is it take when
they collect data they shuffle it and
and here to make it iid and and here I
want to quote my friend Leon Batu who in
his ICML keynote this year said
something like nature does not shuffle
data we shouldn't and the reason why we
shouldn't is because when we do that we
destroy important information about
those changes in distribution that are
inherent in the data we collect and
instead of destroying that information
which we use it in order to learn how
the world changes so this is important
because there are for example rare
events like Black Swan events that are
highly unlikely to happen but could have
severe consequences and this question of
out of distribution jamás ation really
breaks the i-iv hypothesis now the idea
hypothesis was good but if we discard it
we need to replace it by something else
and I'm gonna that's why I've been
talking about priors and one of the
important ones is gonna be well how is
the test distribution gonna be related
to our training distribution if it's if
it's not the same okay so let's talk
about out of this machines realization
what I mean by out of this machine
generalization is essentially the
phenomenon of learner being able to
generalize in some way to a different
distribution it doesn't say anything
about how we do
but let's see why we need this well if
you are a learning agent so agent means
actions right so it's a it's a learning
system that's embedded in some
environment you you are almost always
facing non-stationarity x' for several
reasons right there changes in tribution
due to the actions of the agents I move
to a different place the actions of
other agents the fact that you know I'm
moving that we're looking at different
times different sensory signals
different sensors different traders
different goals different policies all
kinds of things are changing and as you
heard from Blais talk this morning once
we start looking at multi-agent systems
it gets even more complicated you can't
even talk about optimization as he was
explaining but but certainly from the
point of view of each agent you don't
know you don't have a stationary
distribution anymore and if you think
about a child learning for example their
world is changing all the time their
body is changing all the time and so we
need systems that are going to be able
to handle those changes and do things
like continual learning life front
learning and so on this has been a
long-standing goal for machine learning
but I think we haven't yet built the
solutions to this and one of the crucial
elements according to me in order to be
successful in this and I'll come back at
the end of this presentation much more
on this is introducing more forms of
compositionality so so what does that
mean it it means being able to learn
from some finite set of combinations
about a much larger set of combinations
we already get that from distribute
representations these three
representations are really at the heart
of why neural nets are working they were
introduced by geoff hinton in the early
80s and in the last few years we
actually have theory that helps us see
why you get an exponential advantage
potentially at least if if the function
if if you make the right assumptions if
we're making the right assumptions about
the world in terms of compositionality
in terms of being explained by a number
of different variables and factors then
this representations can be
exponentially advantageous because
essentially once you've trained a bunch
of features
you can generalize to new combinations
of those features this is what a single
hidden layer already gives you now if
you have a deeper network you also get
compositionality because each layer gets
composed with the next one and we've
also shown that gives another
exponential advantage and now I think
there are other forms of
compositionality and the one that we
know best is the one you find in
language and linguistic mean I've been
talking about this for a long time they
call it system masticity or system
original ization and and and I'll talk a
lot more about that so this opens the
door to better powers of analogy of
abstract reasoning and that remains to
be done in in machine learning I think
so systemic realization really is aiming
at out of descriptions realization and
fast transfer but but it's about how we
do it it's about the idea that we can we
can get that by dynamically recombining
existing concepts so it could be
language but it could be in other
settings like an in the picture here
from Lake Adel 2015 we invent a new type
of vehicle by combining properties of
different vehicles but what's
interesting about this is dynamic
systematical ization allows potentially
to generalize to combinations that have
zero probability under the training
distribution it's not just that they're
not present in the training data then
they would have zero probability under
the training distribution so as an
example if I tell you a science fiction
scenario clearly you haven't lived
something like this in your life but you
can still imagine it if you if you drive
if you've been living all your life in
you know some continent or some city and
then you move to a completely different
place and you have to drive in this
unknown city as the example I gave
earlier you are also doing a form of
systematic colonization unfortunately
current neural net architectures are not
that good at doing that and it's been
shown through several papers and
experiments starting in particular with
the work of Lake and Baroni
more recently the work
we did at miele led by Padano and and
collaborators presented by a clear
currently we have a paper that's gonna
be on archive probably tomorrow or the
day after on clever which is a dataset
for visual question-answering where
there are combinations of the linguistic
concepts that are present in the
questions that just don't come up in the
way that the data is generated and the
current methods when you ask them to
answer these kinds of questions fail
completely where is the human wouldn't
you know we don't even realize that
these combinations are not present in
the data okay and then one question
people may come up with is how what
you're proposing is different from the
classical AI program of symbolic logic
and so on so that's a good question well
I think there are a number of reasons
why these these classical IR programs
had trouble and in in the work that we
need to do in order to achieve system to
performance we want to avoid some of
these pitfalls we want to make sure that
those systems will be able to generalize
efficiently in a large scale the the the
concepts that we want to learn need to
be grounded in with system one in in
low-level perception and action we we
want to keep the power of generalization
of the distribute representations we
want to make sure that the kind of
search that is involved in things like
reasoning and planning can be done
efficiently whereas the the classical
approaches require a huge number of
explorations of many trajectories of how
things could unfold or how you could
combine concepts rules and so on and
finally we need to make sure we build
systems that can properly handle
uncertainty in the world and machine
learning has been doing a pretty good
job at that up to now but we want to
achieve these extra goals that we're not
very doing during very well at like
systematization that I explained
factorizing the knowledge or T some of
it that the learner is acquiring in
small exchangeable pieces to get
discriminatory advantage that I've been
talking about and that includes being
able to manipulate variables things that
you do not
in programming and in in logic
formulations dealing with instances that
are associated with more general
categories if you want and entry having
references and interaction things that
don't seem natural in the neural net
world but as I'll try to convince you we
now have actually built the tools for
doing that in Indy planning using
attention mechanisms ok so let's talk
about attention and consciousness so
what is attention attention is about
doing computation in a focused way we're
gonna sequentially focus competition on
one or a few elements at a time and we
realized in around 2014 that this was
extremely powerful and and was the
reason why we were able to get a
breakthrough in machine translation when
you when you produce the next word in
English when you're trying to translate
from French say you want to really focus
the competition on just the right few
words in the French sentence that are
relevant to do the translation so we
introduced a particular form of
attention called content-based soft
attention which is very convenient
because you can backdrop through it and
so you can learn it in other words we
can learn where to attend and so the way
it works is the competition being done
at the next level is going to use this
input a selection from the previous
level of computation and that selection
is going to be a soft selection so we
can take a convex weighted combination
of value vectors from the previous level
and these convex weights are coming from
through softmax that is conditioned on
each of the elements so for each of the
elements we're gonna see how well they
match the context to see on which one
the attention should be focused so in a
way attention is peril like we're we're
considering all the possible elements in
some set and we're computing the score
for each of them in order to decide on
which one or which ones we're gonna put
attention and there's been recent work
in cognitive neuroscience showing that
attention should be thought of
as an internal action right so the way
that your brain is is atending it's very
similar to the way that your motor
system is deciding to move your arm and
so we want to learn these attention
policies so attention has been very very
useful
I mentioned machine translation but
essentially today's NLP systems
state-of-the-art systems all rely on
attention look at the older work based
on transformers and their variations
they're also the heart of memory
extended neural nets we had a paper last
year and more ongoing work on how
attention connected to memory can also
unlock the problem of vanishing
gradients and as I'll mention attention
also allows to change your nets from
machines that are processing vectors to
machines that are processing sets and in
particular sets of key value pairs okay
so so let's see this picture again we
can think of attention as creating a
dynamic connection between two layers
whereas in a traditional setting the
connections are fixed here we kind of
pick which of the inputs is going to be
sent to the the whatever module we're
considering that uses an attention
mechanism now this is great but from the
point of view of the receiving module
there is a problem it gets this value
which is one of those in the sets of the
set of input elements but it doesn't
know where it's coming from right it's
the value of what and so what we're
doing it with attention mechanisms is in
addition to the value we have some
concept of key in other words a kind of
identifier for where the value coming is
coming from currently we're using those
keys to decide which element should get
the attention but that key is also sent
to the next level and so downstream
computation can know what the value it's
getting is is what it is what it's
coming from
what kind of object it is what kind of
type it is so you can think of this as
creating a name for these these objects
and creating a form of indirection and
and and as I said now
we have these systems of operating on
sets why is it a set because the
attention mechanism doesn't care of the
order in which we're putting these these
elements in the first layer it just you
know picks one according to how well it
matches the some some kind of learned
policy but the information about the
relative position of these elements in
it say in your brain or in a new linear
architecture it doesn't matter anymore
okay now let's connect to what our
friends in neuroscience and cognitive
science are doing in our community the
the C word consciousness is still kind
of taboo but but in their community it's
not anymore
and that's great they've made a lot of
progress in understanding several
aspects of consciousness and there are a
number of theories but many of them are
related to what's called the global work
space theory which originated from bars
and there's a lot of very good important
improvements to it from standing on and
collaborators and what this theory says
is that what's going on with with
consciousness is there's a bottleneck of
information the some some elements of
what is computed in your brain gets
selected and then broadcast to the rest
of the brain and influencing the rest of
the brain so this is related to
short-term memory where the things that
have been selected are available and
conditions heavily perception and action
so it also gives rise naturally to the
kind of system to abilities that I've
been talking about alright so how is
machine learning going to do something I
mean what's the connection with machine
learning machine learning could be used
to help brain sciences better understand
consciousness but but what we are
understanding of consciousness could
also help machine learning develop
better abilities so first of all the
work that's been done in neuroscience in
general is based on fairly qualitative
descriptions of these functionalities
that we think are associated with
consciousness and what machine learning
can do is help us formalize in in a way
that's you know more mechanistic what
what these exactly means and and then
that could feed back the the research in
in neuroscience in order to provide
specific more specific tests that could
be could be done of these theories of
course for me at least one of the
motivations is also to get rid of the
sort of fuzzy fuzziness and magic that
surrounds the word consciousness and and
and I think machine learning is in a
good position to provide a justification
for these particular forms of
computations in a sense of you know why
do they why have they evolved what kind
of computational and statistical
advantage are coming with these
particular forms of computations and of
course once we understand these things
we also want them in our learning agents
so consciousness is is closely related
to language because the way that we know
that somebody is conscious is by asking
them to report what they're thinking
about so this is the direct way that we
know about consciousness and that means
that there's a very strong link between
your thoughts that in things of you're
conscious of and language that one can
be translated to the other fairly easily
over the loss of information when you go
from your thoughts to to language it
also means that there is a connection
between system 1 and system 2 here
because those high-level concepts that
we communicate with language are
anchored in the system one sort of
intuitive system that connects your
brain to the rest of the world through
through perception and action and and I
think that's one of the big important
direction for natural language research
we really want to explore things like
grounded language learning where we
don't just learn from texts we learn
from environments which involve
perception action
the the perception action loop through
the environment and and allow a learner
not just to get sort of patterns of
sequence of words but but also what they
referred to is as its understanding
potentially implicit of how the world
works
and I refer you here to some work we've
we've done recently in publish to the
last I clear on grounded language
learning something that I called baby AI
okay so now we're at the part of my
presentation when we I'm gonna tell talk
about the kinds of priors the kind of
structures the kind of assumptions and
regularization that we could use in
order to to encourage our learning
systems to do a good job at out of this
efficient realization and the kind of
conscious processing abilities that I've
been talking about and the first one I
want to talk about is the sparse factor
graph assumption I mentioned I called
that in a 2017 paper the conscious is
prior so in this paper I about the way
that cognitive neuroscience has been
understanding conscious process saying
the fact that we form these low
dimensional conscious thoughts that are
obtained by selecting elements from a
larger unconscious state right so so now
instead of having a single top level
representation like we usually have in
our systems we have two there's the a
very high dimensional unconscious state
which contains all of the things you
could think about and then there's a
tiny tiny one which only contains those
that went through the bottleneck
recently that's the conscious state and
then attention of course is used to
select from the first one what goes in
the second one and attention is also
used in a top-down way to condition
further processing in the system one's
computation so now the that way of
thinking about conscious processing is
about the sort of computation we're
doing but in machine learning we also
used to think about what do these
computations
mean and often they mean some kind of
inference with respect to some model of
the world which might be implicit and
and and and a good way to think about a
model of the world includes what what
kind of join distribution between the
high-level concepts are we talking about
and so the consciousness prior proposes
that it's a sparse factor graph so if
factor graph is just a particular
representation of joint distributions
you can represent any joint distribution
in this way it has these squares that
correspond to factors that are kind of
relations between variables the nodes
are other variables and the sparsity
here just has to do with how many
neighbors each node has so why why do I
think that it's a good hypothesis well
think about the the kind of statements
we can make with natural language like
when I say if I drop the ball it will
fall on the ground now this is a very
powerful statement because it's true
with high probability and yet it
involves very few variables just just
the words that are there and so the the
fact that it uses very few words means
that the relationships that are being
described can tightly capture some
element of the joint probability through
very few variables at a time so you can
think of like each of these black
squares each factor corresponding to the
relationship between a small set of
variables of the kind you could produce
with natural language now this is
different from the usual assumption that
you find in many papers these days that
study high-level representations that
are supposed to be in where the
variables are supposed to be independent
of each other this so called
disentangling work which i think is a
misunderstanding of the goals of deep
learning which was to learn these high
level representations and and so instead
of thinking of these variables as
completely independent at the top level
we think of them as having this very
very structured Joint Distribution
and and and they have to be like this
because high level concepts like say
ball and hen that I just used are not
independent they come in these very
powerful
strong relationships as I showed so so
then what I'm saying is instead of
imposing the very strong Trier of
complete marginal independence of the
high light law we can we can have this
slightly weaker prior but still very
strong prior that the joint is
represented by a sparse factor of the
reason I say is still very strong is
that this prior for example would not
work in the space of pixels you can't
find easily a small group of five pixels
in in images such that you can predict
one of the pixels with high accuracy
you've given given the four others but
we can do that with natural language
when we express those statements in this
at this high level so factor graphs are
expressed by writing the joint as a
product of these partition functions
like the 5k here where each of these
partition functions involves only a few
subsets of the variables and so what it
means if we were to impose something
like this is it puts pressure on the
encoder say that map's the low level
data to the high level representations
to have that property that that the
factor graph is sparse okay so next I
want to talk about the meta learning
aspect and another hypothesis that's
important to deal with how the world
changes so butter learning is something
really hot and cool these days but
actually started several decades ago my
brother and I have been working on this
in the early 90s and actually was Sammis
PhD subject and and what it's about
really is about having multiple time
scales of learning or multiple time
scales of iterative optimization like
computation so typically you would have
an inner loop like normal learning and
outer loop like evolution which
optimizes whatever the inner loop is is
producing and so in this way we can talk
about the evolution outer loop with
individual learning in the loop or we
can talk about in the life of an
individual lifetime learning as the
outer loop and individual
adaptation to new environment as the
fastest timescale and the thing that's
cool about meta learning is it allows us
to explicitly optimize for
generalization and in particular it can
be used to explicitly optimize for out
of this visualization right if the agent
sees multiple environments and we can we
can train it's slow timescale meta
parameters so that it will generalize
well to new environments now there's the
question of that I mentioned earlier
what kind of hypothesis can we make
about these changes in distribution and
because underlying physics means that
typically an action by an agent is going
to be localized in space and time we can
assume that the changes in distribution
correspond to are caused by or the
consequence of an intervention by an
agent that acts on just a few causes or
a few mechanisms that relate variables
with each other so this extends
hypothesis that was proposed by shop
cough and collaborators of independent
mechanisms and what they mean here is
informational II independent meaning
that the the relationships between
variables the mechanisms the conditional
distributions are independent in a sense
that what you learned from one doesn't
tell you anything about another one and
so if something changes in the world one
of these mechanisms changes one of the
conditional distributions corresponding
to say one of the nodes in this graph
it's like a graphical model for example
if something like this changes due to an
intervention you only need to adapt the
part of the model of corresponds to
change so for example if I put on some
sunglasses the data that I'm getting at
my my retina is is very very different
but it can be explained by a tiny change
which is this one variable that you know
changes its value from zero to one so
that that's really interesting because
if we have such hypothesis and we have a
good representations of the interactions
between all those high-level variables
then very few bits would be needed to
account for
those changes and this very few
observations needed to adapt or infer
what has happened and this we can get
good out of this visualization so so the
idea is since out of this
personalization can be obtained if we
have a right decomposition of knowledge
we can use out of this machine
performance as a training signal for
factorizing knowledge okay so we did
some work in that direction there's a
paper called a meta transfer objective
for learning to disentangle causal
mechanisms where we apply this idea in a
very simple settings where you have just
two variables a and B or say for
variables a B X Y and a is the cause of
B but the learner doesn't know and you
might observe just X and y which are
simple like rotations of a and B and it
turns out that if you have to write
decomposition if you if you look at the
the right way of factoring the Joint
Distribution between a and B the one in
which we have P of a the cause
multiplied by P of B given a for for the
effect given the cause then when there's
a change in distribution due to an
intervention on the cause the the
learner that has the right model will
adapt much faster doesn't need as much
data so the x axis on this thing is the
amount of data that the learner needs to
recover from a change in P of a and it
turns out that you can also use this to
learn about how to map the X Y which is
things like the pixels that don't have a
causal structure to the A's and B's that
that are the high-level variables that
have causal structure because again the
same remark as I did earlier with the
consciousness prior which does not apply
on the pixel level the assumption that
these tidal variables are causal does
not work on on things like pixels and
you can't really find a pixel that's the
cause of another pixel right so
not the right space for doing things we
had a more recent paper called learning
neural causal models from a known
interventions where we extend these
ideas to larger graphs in such a way
that we can avoid the exponential
explosion of the number of graphs that
need to be considered by permit rising
in a factorized way the distribution
over graphs and one of the things we
find is that in order to really
facilitate the learning of the column
structure the learner should try to
infer what was the intervention on which
variable was the change performed and
that's something we do all the time like
most of the time at least my brain is
trying to figure out what was the cause
of what I've observed or that explained
the change that I am seeing so we tested
these ideas on various small graphs and
we were able to find that actually this
works quite well and better this than
the commonly used causal induction
methods but more importantly the the way
that we are attacking this problem is
something that's very deep learning
friendly in the sense that we just
define an overall objective some
regularization terms usual things and we
do gradient descent on it ok the last
bit of my presentation is about
operating on sets of objects that may be
pointable using dynamically recombined
modules which I promised at the
beginning and so we have another recent
paper called rims for recurrent
independent mechanisms and it's about
motorizing the computation and operating
on these sets of named and typed objects
but in in it in a deep learning way as
you'll see so we we apply this idea to
recurrent maths the state of the
recurrent net is broken into pieces let
me see if this works all right so so
each of these boxes represent a small
recurrent net that is updated based on
its previous take but it can also be
updated based on this
of other seven networks but we are
constraining the way that these sub
networks are talking to each other so
that it's going to be sparse and it's
going to be done in a dynamic way so
what it means is that using attention
mechanisms the the connectivity pattern
between those those modules is is
changed and and and computed on-the-fly
also we use the attention mechanisms to
select a subset of the modules that are
going to be activated so this is the
idea that there's a bottleneck that
dominates the computation and and the
other important element is that the
things that are communicated between
those sub networks are not the usual
standard vectors that we use in
recurrent Nets they are these sets of
key value pairs and so what it means is
that what these networks are exchanging
is you can think of them as variables
along with something like their type and
what we found is that this leads to
better out of this machine
generalization then standard methods
that don't use these kind of structures
we've also tested this in reinforcement
learning setups where we just replaced
LST M's that were used in in a PPO
baseline for our terry games and found
that it helped on the majority of the
atari games okay so we are close to the
end of my presentation let me recap some
of the hypotheses for conscious
processing by agents and system original
ization that i'm proposing we pay more
attention to so I mentioned the the
consciousness prior this idea that there
would be a sparse factor graph relating
the Joint Distribution between the
high-level semantic variables I
suggested that these high-level
variables for the most part can be
considered as causal variables that they
can be cause or effect of each other and
what it means really is that they they
are about agents they are about
intentions and they are about objects
that are controllable and their
attributes one thing I didn't talk about
is that those those relationships
between variables they there
they don't have their own parameters for
each factor of the graph for each
potential function instead they should
be shared modules that can be reused
across different tuples so the fact that
we have these key value pairs that means
that a particular say sub network is
going to receive input that's going to
be different depending on the context
and so it's like if it's a little rule
but of course it's a neural net that is
going to be applied to different
instances so the the the graphical model
that I'm talking about is more like a
dynamic Bayes net where the same
parameters can be reused in many many
places this course this is also
connected to Markov logic networks that
Domingos propose a long time ago
another really important hypothesis that
I spend time on is the idea that the
changes in this fusion are mostly
localized if you represent information
in the right way and this semantic space
so that's another property of that
semantic space and one thing I didn't
spend much time on but that for example
are just Qian boat who have talked about
in their recent paper is that the things
that are preserved across those changes
in distribution have to do with the
stable properties of the world that
could be for example grounded by an
encoder system one aspect that captured
is stable and robust aspects of the
world so to conclude I think after
decades of work on consciousness by
container science it's time that machine
learning looked at these questions and
explore the functionalities and and and
the justifications for having these
kinds of capabilities and I think that
this would bring new priors that could
help system original ization and out of
distribution generalization it could
benefit of course neuroscience because
we would be able to provide more
detailed account of these
functionalities that can then be tested
in in real people or animals and it
would allow to expand deep learning from
system
system - so thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much your chef is its
great dog so please if you have
questions come on the left side or the
right sides close to the mic sorry hey
um so you're talking about consciousness
and this is something I think that's
really interesting um I think there's
actually pretty broad consensus among
moral philosophers that conscious having
conscious experience is an important
part of what makes one a moral patient
in order in other words like deserving
of moral consideration and then
philosophers also like to talk about
like the easy problem of consciousness
versus the hard problem of consciousness
and I'm kind of just wondering you know
what your thoughts are on the moral
implications of building machines that
may be conscious and if you think the
way that you're talking about
consciousness has any relevance to that
kind of question and also if you think
that there's a way that you see for us
to determine whether or not AI systems
that we're building are having
subjective experiences that make them
relevant moral patients so today I've
only talked about the easy problem of
consciousness there is the question of
subjective experience which haven't
talked about and deserves much more work
and attention but on the neuroscience
side people have been thinking about
this for much longer and there are some
interesting theories which I think
connect to issues of self-knowledge and
predicting our own actions which might
explain the the impression of subjective
experience so over here the other major
theory of consciousness is of course
integrated information theory which
measures consciousness by this fie
quantity which is essentially a measure
of the mutual information or the parts
of the system and the higher the mutual
information the more consciousness you
have which seems like the polar opposite
of your sparse factor graph hypothesis
how do you reconcile the two I don't
so I think the iit theory is more on the
mystical side of things and you know
attributes consciousness to any atom in
the universe and I'm more interested in
the kind of consciousness that we can
actually see in brains
no but they measure consciousness by
this five measure in brains yes there is
a quantity that is being measured that I
don't think it's related to the kind of
computational abilities that have been
talking about hi here thank you for the
very inspirational talk my question is
regarding so the the topics that you
touched upon the prior part and also the
factorization part so in recent
cognition work it has also been shown
that the human mind kind of uses this
the spatial world where we navigate as
kind of a prior to sort our thoughts and
this has been recently summarized also
in the book by bob reverse key if I
don't know if you're familiar with that
but my question is do you see like a
role for for this kind of like spatial
prior or like a way to organize certain
concepts and how could we go about this
yeah yeah possibly I think one of the
big lessons of the last few decades of
machine learning is we need all kinds of
priors in order to encourage good
solutions to the problems we're looking
at and clearly the brain is excluding
the fact that a very important aspect of
the world is the spatial structure of
course some of our models do but I think
on the conscious side and memory side
these are also important but I haven't
looked at that thanks thank you over
here I'm inspired and also heartened to
see that you're exploring how to
integrate some aspects of as you what
you put the symbolic program into deep
learning and so on I guess my question
is how far you anticipate that going
there's been a lot of work for example
on extending logic programming which is
far more powerful than
just knowledge graphs or graphs or
hypergraphs to have numerical
uncertainty including scalably
computationally scalably
so that might involve interleaving
fine-grain these kinds of symbolic
reasoning techniques with neural network
type learning and inference as it's
usually conceived of in neural net or
machine learning terms so how much of
that how soon do you think there ought
to be well so indeed there are a lot of
people who have been exploring how we
could kind of paste the symbolic logic
tools on top of the neural net
computation I don't think this will work
what I'm talking about is interleaving
it yeah tightly as opposed to just
bolting it on before but so what I'm
talking about is different and and yeah
of course I've you know I don't know
what will work I don't have a crystal
ball but what I'm talking about is more
implementing some of the functionalities
of logic and reasoning with the neural
net machinery in the hope of keeping you
know both properties and in one place I
didn't have time to talk about where
this matters is in the search so in in
classical AI a bid up big obstacle is we
have to look through a potential
expansion large number of potential
trajectories or combinations of things
and that's where system 1 which is the
neural net then comes in right so we
learn what to attend to what to think
about but it happens out of our
consciousness we don't know why we think
about something but that's crucial to
enable efficient reasoning and search
and planning and so on well thanks and
we talk more about it later thanks for
great talk yeah I'm curious to hear your
thoughts on what is the data
distribution and how we know if we're in
it or out of it and how the data
distribution like what is the
relationship between
the data distribution in the empirical
distribution like how given a training
set can we exactly characterize what is
the underlying distribution of that data
well obviously we don't have access to
the data distribution except if we're
doing machine learning experiments and
we sort of cheat and and you know
synthesize the data from some handmade
distribution and so we can do it
mathematically we can do it in
simulations where we know what it is and
it's very useful but I think we also
have to think about maybe how that
distribution came about as a
non-stationary process where things
change in the world and sometimes what
looks like a distribution can be broken
down into sub distributions that that
are related think about data coming from
different places or different times for
example and and we don't pay enough
attention to that right now
hi a quick question so you made a call
to move beyond just perception to
higher-level reasoning and consciousness
and the question is how do we actually
measure progress towards that goal
so I talked about out of distribution
organization right and things like
transfer learning few short learning
continual learning and so on have
benchmarks which i think is a good
starting point but but in general
especially if we introduce the the agent
aspect we I think we have to start
thinking about building environments in
which we're going to test how well our
learner can cope with those changes in
distribution when those changes are not
like a simple set of distributions like
we do right now in standard but the meta
learning benchmarks for example yeah I'm
here
so you set these high high level
semantic variables you said in one point
you said they're in a factor graph and
then you also said they're causal yes
usually the causal one causal variables
will put them into tags yes so yeah can
you say something on the release just
put arrows on the photograph
and that works okay well I mean so you
you have the Joint Distribution
structure and and the causality is just
another thing on top which provides
extra information and these are the
arrows I mean there could be a longer
answer but that's the short answer
high to the right high so great talk
thank you my question is what
relationship you see between sparse
factor graphs and relational and
associative memory supported by the
hippocampus in humans given that humans
with bilateral hippocampal removal
appear to be able to be conscious but
not flexibly use relational associations
that's interesting I didn't know about
it so I don't know I guess maybe you
need that attention going back and forth
between the two sides of the brain in
order to to coordinate the different
elements of say our relations so so one
thing maybe that has been misleading in
my picture is I've drawn the conscious
state as if it was some something that
was physically separate from the
unconscious state but in the brain
that's not how it is it's more like
within you know the brain the
unconscious part is some some subset of
neurons become excited a lot more and
others become inhibited so in and of
course that goes through a global
communication so if you break the global
communication I could imagine it would
it would hurt the whole thing the coffee
break and we are going to thank again
Lucia
you